so some of you folks may have already
heard that the us army has caught a lot
of flak from the esports and streaming
world
from cringe tweets to allegedly fake
giveaways to chat bands that might be
unconstitutional
it has been a wild couple of days for
the us armed forces on twitch but with
the announcement that the us army is
pausing their twitch streams and with
chat unfurling the mission accomplished
banners
i think now might be a good time to take
a step back and walk you through what
the hell happened here
how did the us army lose the war for
twitch
[Music]
all right before we get into this story
i want to make sure that you all know
that if you want more esports gaming and
streaming news like this
then you should watch clouded it's a
weekly show we do on wednesday at 1 pm
eastern over at twitch.tv slashes for
esports where
we talk about news we have opinions and
we make fun of colin for being a boomer
it's a good time
anyway this whole us army thing kind of
started on june 30th
when the us army esports team got in a
conversation with discord on twitter
which they ended with an so obviously
that's super [ __ ] cringy
doubly so coming from the us army but it
made a lot of people realize
wait the us army has an esports team and
yeah they do it's kind of weird but they
have an esports team called the us army
esports and they've been around since
november 2018. they've been kind of
low-key but
they have been around the u.s armed
forces have been using esports and
gaming as a recruitment platform for
years
america's army is a series of video
games developed and published by the us
army since 2002.
meanwhile in esports the u.s air force
sponsored e-league and the boston major
and if you don't remember a uniformed
air force sergeant came out to give
skadoodle the mvp trophy at the boston
major
but not everyone has been super
comfortable with the us armed forces
presence in esports and gaming over the
years
there has been criticism of the us army
esports team much like there's criticism
of
any recruitment material that the us
army puts out and if you don't believe
me
just take a look at the responses to
their initial tweet many people view the
aiming of military recruitment material
at younger people
as problematic you've got young
impressionable people being told that
playing a life of video games has
somehow prepared them for an
actual armed conflict whether you
support the existence of a military or
not
that doesn't make a lot of sense some
have said that u.s army esports doesn't
just promote an unrealistic image of
what being in the military is actually
like
but they're also targeting their message
at people who may not have the skills to
be in the army
but are more receptive to the message
because they're playing video games
about shooting people
now that doesn't mean that everyone is
against recruitment just that there are
some serious ethical questions about
aiming recruitment material at
gamers but what happened next is when
things really went off the rails for us
army esports
on july 1st a day after that cringe wu
tweet people decided to make a game of
speedwriting getting banned from the us
army's discord server
mostly by linking a wikipedia article
that lists u.s war crimes
and on july 8 esports twitter guy rod
slasher breslau shared a video of
activist and political consultant jordan
ull going into the us army twitch chat
and typing
what's your favorite war crime we'll
then link that wikipedia article about
u.s war crimes before getting banned
shortly after
oh cool nice really chill guy
have a nice time getting banned my dude
the streamer at the time was
joshua strontium a 12-year army veteran
and between his reaction and wool
getting banned
people decided to see if they could get
on the us army's bad side too
chat was quickly inundated with more
people asking about u.s war crimes and
quickly getting banned themselves and
the us army wasn't the only branch of
the u.s armed forces to get ban happy on
twitch
wool went over to the us navy's twitch
channel and did the whole war crime
stick there too
leading to him getting banned and of
course more people getting banned for
doing it as well
and in the middle of all this wool
reported that the us army was posting
links in their twitch chat that they
said were links to a giveaway to win an
xbox elite series 2 controller
and allegedly they actually led to a
recruitment form when i reached out to
the us army for more information on what
happened
and if they were aware that the links
they were sending out led to recruitment
forms
they said that the giveaways are in fact
real and that they've given away 10
controllers setups and chairs over the
last year
we have a standard form that is used for
all activities but each action has a
marketing code associated with it to
ensure the submissions are connected to
the correct event or giveaway
the team is exploring options to
customize its giveaway pages to provide
more external clarity
kotaku's nathan grayson reported on july
16th that twitch has intervened and
forced the us army to remove their
giveaway links now i want to take a
second to say that i think
most people who are posting about us war
crimes and getting banned in twitch chat
weren't doing it because they were
questioning the morality of recruiting
gamers on twitch
i have to imagine that a lot of people
getting in on this just wanted to get in
on a big trolling campaign
but many people do feel strongly about
this many
myself included feel very uncomfortable
with the us armed forces trying to use
twitch as an arm to recruit gamers
and some people even feel like these
twitch bans might be unconstitutional
lawyers at the knight first amendment
institute at columbia university
representing jordan ul say that banning
him and
others from the u.s army and navy twitch
chats was unconstitutional and a
violation of their rights to free speech
the army and navy esports teams banning
of users based on their speech about war
crimes is unconstitutional
when the government intentionally opens
a space to the public at large for
expressive activity it has created a
public forum under the first amendment
and it cannot constitutionally bar
speakers from that forum based on
viewpoint
these principles apply with full force
in the digital sphere including on
social media platforms as courts have
emphasized in recent cases basically the
us army and
navy twitch channels are a
government-backed open forum
which means banning u.s citizens for
discussing war crimes
is unconstitutional and violates their
right to free speech
now when i reached out to the us army i
asked for their comment on the
accusation that banning ool and others
from their twitch channel was
unconstitutional
and here's what they told me the esports
team members did not ban the users
because of viewpoints they banned them
for behavior intended to harass degrade
and intimidate
which violates the twitch community
guidelines since the team started on
twitch they have had specific chat rules
on the page that clearly states
harassing behavior will not be tolerated
those chat rules include not harassing
people not spamming or otherwise
disrupting the stream and not pushing
personal agendas
quote again with respect to banning
users the us army esports team's social
media pages were being spammed with
what's your favorite war crime memes and
questions
the esports team blocked the term war
crimes in its twitch channel after
discovering the trend was meant to troll
and harass the team
twitch members used creative spelling to
continue related posts
following the guidelines and policies
set by twitch the us army esports team
banned users from its account due to
concern over posted content
and website links that were considered
harassing and degrading in nature
and when i reached out to the us navy
they gave me a pretty similar answer
we moderate our channel in accordance
with our posted channel rules
which are available to everyone who
chooses to participate in the chat
we strive to allow for maximum freedom
of discussion in our chat
and seek to only ban those who break the
posted rules or engage in personal
attacks against our streamers or their
families
we have a system whereby offenders are
given several chances to correct
infractions
prior to being banned and our moderators
will engage with those who violate the
rules to inform them of which channel
rules they have broken
this is done in an attempt to allow for
maximum amount of free civil and open
discourse
if someone feels like they have been
unfairly manned they have every right to
contact a moderator for an explanation
and possible unbanning now the lawyers
at the knight institute
already have a response lined up for
that they say quote
mr ul's speech does not constitute
harassment under the terms of service
which define harassment to mean any
content or activity that attempts to
intimidate the grade abuse or creates a
hostile environment for others
mr ul's messages drew attention to prior
us military actions
in the context of the army and navy's
use of twitch as a recruiting tool
his messages were quintessential
political speech which lie
at the core of the first amendment so it
seems like the us army may have
really [ __ ] up here which is why
they're taking a break
when i reached out they told me the
esports team is reviewing ways to
customize its giveaway submission forms
and provide more clarity for each of its
giveaways
the team has pawn streaming to review
internal policies and procedures
as well as platform-specific policies to
ensure guidelines for participating in
the space are clear before streaming
resumes
oh and to top this all off vice reported
that alexandre ocasio-cortez
the silver 3 league player and u.s
representative from new york
has filed an amendment to a house
appropriations bill which would prevent
the u.s military from using funds the
bill would provide to quote
maintain a presence on twitch.com or any
video game esports or live streaming
platform
basically the us army is taking an
indefinite break from streaming while
they figure stuff
out and if aoc's amendment goes through
which to be fair
is not guaranteed they may not be able
to come back at all
honestly if this weren't about the us
armed forces
this would all sound like a pretty
normal twitch controversy but then again
they are in fact the us armed forces and
that's what makes this whole mess
a real problem up until now i've tried
to give you the facts in as clear a way
as i can
people have been banned lawyers say
those bans are unconstitutional
giveaway links allegedly led to
recruitment forms the army is working on
making those giveaway links
clearer but now that the facts are laid
out i want to tell you what i think of
all this
because i think that attempts to recruit
or market the us armed forces
via twitch esports and gaming are shady
as hell
i find it deeply uncomfortable that the
us armed forces are trying to recruit
people via twitch and esports events
especially when sometimes those people
aren't even officially positioned as
recruiters
on the us army esports teams website it
says
members of the esports outreach team are
not recruiters
which sure but this whole page is hosted
on recruitment.army.mill
so they might not officially be
recruiters but they're part of a
recruitment effort so come
on and earlier on the page it says quote
they will operate much like the golden
knights and army marksmanship unit to
create awareness about the army and
opportunities it provides
the golden knights and amu are
competitive teams in parachuting and
shooting respectively
they exist to market the army and make
people more aware of what they do
but those few words at the end are
really telling they don't just create
awareness about the army they tell you
about the
opportunities it provides and even the
people who are in charge of these kinds
of programs agree
in an article posted all the way back in
february 2019
sergeant first class christopher jones
the nco in charge of the team
said that team members will receive a
crash course on army enlistment programs
to answer questions from those
interested in learning about the service
so basically they're not official
recruiters but they are
trained to help recruit and over on the
navy side of things
it's just as murky vices matthew galt
reports that one of the navy streamers
said
on stream we're not here to recruit but
vice discovered the navy's guide to
twitch streaming in which they state
everything done on social media should
be aimed at making connections between
prospects and recruiters i reached out
to the us navy and a spokesperson told
me this
mm-1 cross-white statement is accurate
mm-1 is not a recruiter and his role on
the team is to play games on esports and
be there to talk with followers about
his experiences in the navy
in order to raise awareness about navy
opportunities if that results in people
wanting to learn more about the navy
then we are happy to help point them in
the right direction the purpose of our
esports team is to bring awareness to
the navy while competing and engaging
with the gaming community
naturally such outreach efforts may
result in users asking about careers in
the navy if users express an interest or
curiosity about joining the navy the
team member will take that conversation
offline and first request the age of the
individual if an interested user is over
the age of 17
then the esports team member will
recommend they visit navy.com where they
can speak to a recruiter
again they might not be recruiters
themselves on stream but they're there
to connect you to a recruiter they are
part of the recruitment effort
and they even say in that quote there's
a potential that
they're marketing to people under the
age of 17. so why are the us armed
forces so
thirsty to recruit gamers well way back
in 2018 the associated press reported
that the us army missed their
recruitment goals for the first time
since 2005.
their recruitment efforts weren't
working the same way anymore so
now they're turning to gaming a space
where people regularly play games about
pretending to shoot people in armed
conflicts
and look i think everyone watching this
video will agree with me
that there is a pretty huge difference
between playing cs go
and signing up to be an actual real-life
ct the skills are not comparable
the headspace is not the same and if i'm
being perfectly honest
one is a lot less morally dubious than
the other and if you need a hint
it's the one where no one actually gets
shot look i don't necessarily hold
anything against an individual who joins
the armed forces
but i do think that the armed forces
trying to convince people that playing
games has prepared them to serve in an
armed conflict
is super not okay this is preying on
young impressionable
often disenfranchised people and telling
them that serving in the armed forces is
the escape they need
or that it's the true test of their
elite gaming skills
and don't think that this stops at
twitch streams the us army have so
so many partnerships with gaming and
esports organizations
i already told you that the us air force
sponsored e-league but they also
sponsored cloud9
and the us navy has partnerships with
esl twitch evil geniuses and doubletap
they're planning on making content that
advertises how esports compares to being
in the navy
spoilers i don't think it really does
now to be fair to the us army and navy
that is not how they see it i asked the
navy how they felt about the immense
scrutiny they faced from the gaming and
streaming world over the last couple of
days and
here's what they told me we understand
that some people in the gaming community
oppose the military and have no interest
in a navy career
but for those who are curious about what
it is like to serve the navy is
committed to utilizing platforms that
provide opportunities for authentic
conversations the u.s armed forces
want you and i to look at them
positively whether they're trying to
recruit specifically us
or not they want to be seen as an
overall good in the world which
personally really scares me because that
means that they're using esports and
gaming as a propaganda tool
and if you think that they aren't
remember that they literally banned
people for talking about u.s war crimes
no matter how much fun we have playing
cod and cs go
war isn't fun and i don't think the u.s
armed forces have any
place in esports especially if they're
out here trying to make us think that
war actually is fun
there's no good just clip of an
unfortunately
it's not like an actual thing an anime
girl character would say
you know what i mean oh oh dan you
underestimated me so much
oh yeah okay because i really wanted to
just put an anime character going
with the [ __ ] like us army logo over
their face or something
oh my gosh